[Music]
daddy needs to express some rage
[Music]
well hello there and what's up reaction
faction it's deadpool
don't forget to smash that subscribe
button and follow me on patreon last
week you all really liked my cruella
trailer reaction video
where are the [ __ ] dogs so this week
i'll be reacting to a trailer for a
movie which i honestly thought came out
like
a year ago free guy apparently it's this
august
we also have a guest reactor this week
korg
who was not my first choice but
apparently everyone else was too busy
over on disney plus
say hello korg hello made of rocks thank
you for having me paul
sorry you did jesus christ let's take a
look
my name is guy oh he's named guy like
the movie's title that's pretty clever
is it i've got a best friend this is the
greatest cup of coffee of all time
mondays am i right joe you said it guys
let's just pause for a second let
everyone comment
first or this trailer gives away too
much or ryan reynolds is just me which
is super insulting by the way
all done and i work at the bank
i thought i had everything i needed but
then
i met her oh jody calmer
god i love her so much oh i hope they
don't fridge her
what's fridging uh well it's the
practice of killing off or hurting a
female character in order to motivate or
torture the main character also known as
deadpool 2. thank you for asking
ah we call that bridging
everybody down on the ground everybody
accept you
there's something inside you guys that
expected you to just fall it's like a
hostage situation
more than that put these on okay fine
oh my god
[Music]
what are these trick glasses or
something it's about your glasses
the glass checker this world it's a
video game
you're not real please
i'm the guy responsible for this world
any thoughts on our villain cork
uh looks like he's got four arms and the
two lower ones
they've got gloves on i like them you
have a disney
plush show don't you face oh god
oh trademark infringement does that mean
that nothing you do matters
i am sitting here with my best friend
trying to help him get through a tough
time
now that's not real i don't know what it
is i know this world
look at him go that little blue shirt oh
his face is so punchable next guy i'm
gonna be the great guy
well enjoy your lifetime supply of
virginity
this whole good guy routine is ruining
the game
terminator let's take a whitey t he
seems quite nice actually
rabbit maybe this is the live-action
thumper we all haven't been waiting for
jump jump don't break the ball
no useless
[Applause]
wow body airbag love it i can't die
clean bad's going to be
[Music]
okay this looks fun in a in a last days
of fox fire sale kind of way
not sure if it was worth diverting
canadian cumberbatch's little mind away
from my next movie or
you know what i'm gonna give it uh i'll
give it four out of five avocados cork
i was raised by avocados oh my god just
kill me now
any uh any tips on uh getting into the
mcu there cork
uh have a dream uh chase it
lose that dream just sabotage all sorts
of happiness
in pursuit of that dream climb up to the
peaks of that mountain
and when you get to the top land at the
bottom and realize you're never going to
achieve that dream
and at that point check your emails
maybe you'll get something from your
agent saying
marvel wants to talk yeah i prefer dark
world
half a [ __ ] penny of you for this
[Music]
huh